what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back from my final plot league video of
the season and I'm sure most of you
heard my plot league video about episode
six but in that video I told you I would
make another one for the season 7 finale
the original plot leaked was posted on
Reddit back in October but it was only
an outline but since then a way for the
lads started to release more and more
details about each episode so I'm just
gonna read to you everything that it
says for the finale keep in mind some of
this might not be in the correct order
but it does seem like most of it is and
you also have to remember none of this
is confirmed yet so we're gonna have to
wait and see how much of this is true
but let's begin anyway the episode
begins in King's Landing and this is
where Daenerys brings the unsullied into
frackie just in case Cersei has a trap
set for her she places her armies right
outside of King's Landing stores and
this is where Jaime and Bronn are
overseeing King's Landing defenses and
they see all of Danny's armies outside
of King's Landing 'he's doors and they
admire it tearing and the others take a
ship and they arrive at King's Landing
and once they are docked Tyrion Jon
Daenerys Jorah Davos Theon the Hound who
has the white in a cage as well as
Daenerys as Dothraki bloodrider 'he's
are awaited by bran when they arrive
Brienne and the Hound see each other and
Brienne is amazed that the Hound is
somehow alive they talk about Arya and
the Hound ask Brienne if she should be
the one who's protecting her Bryan says
that the only person needing protecting
is the one who gets an aria sway the
Hound smiles and he says he doesn't plan
on being the one to do that another
reunion is with Tyrion and Podrick and
Podrick still admires Tyrion and loves
him and he even says to him that Tyrion
is still his lord while tearing is there
he looks around the dragon pit thinking
it could be a trap Cersei arise with
Qyburn Euron and the mountain there is
no cleganebowl in this episode but the
mountain and the hound do see each other
and the Hound gives him a look that says
one day I will finish you off The Hound
brings in the cage with the captured
white to the middle of the dragon pit
Cersei as Tyrion warden heiresses which
is when Daenerys arrives on top a drug
on with Rey golf lying at her side
everyone is amazed by this even Cersei
and Euron but then Cersei wonders where
third dragon is but the person who is
most amazed as your own by dragon's
arrival Fiona in urine also have a
reunion at the dragon pit and your own
challenges Theon by asking him if he's
ever gonna do anything about his sister
Yara
Theon says he will touch on that later
John then tries to explain that the
great other is real and they need to
unite to come out victorious Cersei
doesn't believe John but the Hound opens
the whites cage and the white comes out
like a wild beast running towards Cersei
but the Hound also has him chained up so
he can't reach her Cersei is surprised
by this and she's afraid and this is
when the Hound starts to demonstrate how
a white cannot be killed by just
chopping it up bit by bit since it
continues to move even when the Hound
cuts it up John yells out that there are
only two ways to kill a white first is
what fire so they set fire to one of the
White's arms and the arm stops moving in
the white displays pain the second is
what dragonglass and John uses something
to stab the white and that's when the
white dies this is when we hear John's
speech from the trailer about the Great
War Euron pretends to be afraid and
Euron asks how many of these creatures
are there to what john says hundreds of
thousands
Euron asked john if they can swim and
john says no so that's when Euron says
well I'm gonna go back to Pyke and
that's when he leaves Cersei and
Daenerys see the danger together but
Cersei says once the long night is over
she must still be queen and she offers
John to be the warden of the north
but Jonathan swears an oath to Dany in
front of everyone John says he can only
serve one queen and his queen is
Daenerys Targaryen Cersei is very
surprised that a northern savage has
said something like this Cersei is
pissed off and she leaves and she's
unwilling to collaborate because she is
not going to be bending the knee to
Daenerys Brienne tries to convince Jaime
to change Circe's mind Jaime says he
admires her loyalty to the Starks but
Bryan says [__] loyalty it's about
survival Jaime has seen all this any
believes the long night and he says he's
going to do his best
now that tearing and John and Daenerys
have seen Circe's negative response it
might mean that they won't have the
support of the southern armies as
support in the north
Tyrion heads to the red keep with the
mountain right behind
Tyrion and Cersei have a conversation
about how she blames him for all of the
things that the Lannisters have gone
through she talks about how he killed
their mother and father and Tyrion said
there was nothing he could do
Tywin wanted him dead so he killed him
instead
then Tyrion says if I'm so evil why
don't you order the mountain to kill me
Cersei doesn't give the command Terry
and notices Cersei isn't drinking any
wine so he knows she must be pregnant
and she doesn't deny this Tyrion and
Cersei walk out to meet the rest of the
people that are in the dragon pit and
Cersei tells them that after speaking
with Tyrion she will send troops to the
north to help against the others Tyrion
and Daenerys talk about how Daenerys
told Jon she can't have any children how
the dragons are her only children but
Jon doesn't care if she can't have any
children up in Winterfell
Sean's own Littlefinger have a
discussion Littlefinger tells songs of
that Arya is very dangerous why would
she choose to come back to Winterfell
now what will Oriya do with the letter
this is all part of Littlefinger's plan
to split the sisters apart Daenerys and
her group leave the dragon pit and they
go back to the war room on Dragonstone
they talk about organizing their
defenses and since Jory is good at
strategies he tells them that they need
to use their forces for a defensive
strategy when the dead come south Theon
and Jon speak about the Starks and the
Greyjoy's and how it used to be when
they grew up together John as Theon if
he's gonna come north with them but fian
says no because he must rescue his
sister Yara first now that Theon knows
you're is still alive since you're on
challenged him
Theon tries to rally the rest of the
Ironborn that's on Dragonstone to help
him rescue Yara
but he ends up getting in a fight with
one of the men fiona is getting beat up
pretty badly but the man tries to kick
fiona in the balls and it does nothing
and that's when feelin's able to get the
upper hand and win after the fight Theon
takes a small rescue group with them off
of Dragonstone and they head out for
Yara back in Winterfell Sansa gathers
all the northern Lords and all the Vale
leaders Sansa calls Arya to come forward
and Arya thinks this might be her last
day alive
Sansa says it's time to judge the great
treacheries in betrayals that have been
done to the north and that they're gonna
judge the person who is responsible
Sansa look straight at Arya and she
actually can't believe that songs is
about to do this but sauna then repeats
herself but this time she looks right at
Littlefinger sauna then starts to list
off everything he has done she talks
about Littlefinger killing Liza Erin she
also pulls out the dagger and asked him
if he recognized the dagger that he said
belong to Tyrion but they knew was his
brain is next to Songza and he's
actually the one who told her all of
this and she tells everyone that
Littlefinger sold her off to the
Bolton's and this is when Littlefinger
realizes he is screwed he tries to lie
his way out of it and he even asked Lord
Royce for some help but he realizes
there is going to be no way out of this
and this is when Shonda thanks him for
all of the lessons that he has taught
her and this is when arya comes up from
behind him and she slices his story back
in King's Landing Jaime and Cersei have
a conversation about the upcoming war
Jaime doesn't know that Cersei has no
intention of helping him yet
Jaime starts looking at the map on the
floor because he wants to prepare the
Lannisters army to go north and help but
this is when Cersei asked him what he's
doing Jaime tells her he's getting ready
to head north but Cersei tells him no
they're not going to be helping them
Cersei tells Jaime that she has obtained
an agreement with Euron when he
pretended to be a coward and he said he
was going to go back to Pyke Euron is
actually going to Essos to hire the
golden company to help her defeat
Daenerys Jaime is disgusted by this and
they continue to argue and the mountain
actually draws his sword in case things
get ugly between the two Jaime is so
angry he actually leaves in the mountain
lets him through he is seen leaving
King's Landing on his own heading north
on a horse we see Jaime leaving the city
and on his way out he stops to fix his
golden hand and this is when he looks
back at the red cape and this is when
the first snowflakes begin to fall on
King's Landing back in Winterfell brain
is visited by Sam who he recognized from
when Sam helped him get north of the
wall bran as Sam what he's doing there
and sam said he needs to speak with Jon
and brain says he also needs to tell Jon
some things Sam asked bran what he needs
to tell Jon and branch as that John
isn't Ned's bastard but he is Liana and
Rhaegar son he says that he was born in
Dorne and his name is in Jon Snow ether
his name is actually John sand Sam tells
bran he actually isn't a sand either he
has seen the record about Rey gars
annulment
with Elia and his new marriage with
Liana Sam says that if bran can see into
the past he should go and see for
himself what's bran does he sees the
wedding with Rhaegar and Lyanna in a
forest and brain realizes Robert's
rebellion was all based on a lie because
Robert was angry and thought Liana was
kidnapped and raped while brain is
having this flashback it goes back and
forth between his flashback and John and
Daenerys on the boat heading north John
and Daenerys enter a cabin together on
the boat and they begin to take off each
others clothes and have epic boat sex
Tyrion is the only one who notices they
are having sex
and while the romance starts to
intensify we flashback to the Tower of
joy scene where Liana tells Ned that her
baby's name is Aegon Targaryen bran then
says Aegon Targaryen is the legitimate
heir to the Iron Throne Arya and Sansa
finally make up and reconcile Arya tells
Songza that she's the strongest woman
she has ever met and so Anza tells her
that she could have never achieved the
things that Arya has the last scene is
at the wall we see the events through
the eyes of bran while he is Ward into a
bunch of crows it's at Eastwatch where
torment and barek are at we see the army
of the dead with the Blizzard following
them torment America shocked as they see
this and out of nowhere the night king
flies in on Vasari on this Ariane starts
to do flybys attacking the wall with a
blue flame it starts to focus on one
part of the wall that starts melting the
wall starts to break apart into a
v-shape which leaves the wall open to
the great other and this is when the
episode ends with the night king flying
right through the wall on Vissarion ari
folks that's everything I have for the
finale I know there is a lot to take in
here considering this episode will be
the longest episode in Game of Thrones
history it should be right around 80
minutes long but there is a massive
revelation in this the wedding between
Rhaegar and Lyanna is huge Jon Snow
could potentially be the legitimate heir
to the Iron Throne and his real name
might actually be a contour garyun
that's pretty damn crazy also John and
Danny having sex may lead to something
pretty important later they keep saying
Daenerys can't have any kids but I'm
100% confident she will get pregnant by
John like I said before marry master
told the Narus that only death can pay
for life and I think since vissarion
died that
be sort of like a payment for life and
it's gonna allow Daenerys to get
pregnant once again I could be wrong
about that but it feels like they're
gonna go in this direction with all the
foreshadowing they are doing with John
and Daenerys let me know what you think
though based off this do you think the
finale is going to be good or bad I'm
wondering how all of you feel I want to
thank you all for stopping by to watch
the video I really do appreciate that
and I also want to thank all my patreon
supporters I hope everyone has a great
day
bye
you